and then
the matching idea to that of artificial
intelligence with the hutter prize
you know i'm torn i go back and forth on
what i think about it
yeah but the the the basic thesis
is it's nice it's a nice compelling
notion that
we can reduce the task of creating an
intelligent system a general
intelligence system
into the task of compression so you can
think of all of intelligence in the
universe in fact
as a kind of compression
do you find that was that just at the
time you found that as a compelling idea
do you still find that
a compelling idea i still find that
compelling idea
um i think that it's not that useful
day-to-day
but actually um one of maybe my quests
before that was a search for the
definition of the word intelligence
and i never had one and i definitely
have a definition of the word
compression
it's a very uh simple uh straightforward
one
and uh you know what confession is you
know what lossless is lossless
compassion not lossy lossless
compression
and that that is equivalent to
intelligence which i believe
i'm not sure how useful that definition
is day-to-day but like i now have a
framework to understand what it is
and he just 10xed the uh the prize for
that competition like recently a few
months ago
you ever thought of taking a crack at
that oh i did
oh i did i spent i spent the next after
i found the prize i spent the next
six months of my life trying it and uh
well that's when i started learning
everything about
ai and then i worked vicarious for a bit
and then i learned
read all the deep learning stuff and i'm
like okay now i like i'm caught up to
modern ai
wow and i had i had a really good
framework to put it all in from the
compression stuff
right like some of the first uh some of
the first deep learning models i played
with were
uh gpt basically
but before transformers before it was
still uh rnn's
to to do character prediction but by the
way on the compression side
i mean the especially neural networks
what do you make of the lossless
requirement with the hutter prize so
you know human intelligence and and
neural networks can probably compress
stuff
pretty well but there it will be lossy
it's imperfect
uh you can turn a lossy compressor into
a lossless compressor pretty easily
using an arithmetic encoder right you
can take an arithmetic encoder
and you can just encode the noise with
maximum efficiency
right so even if you can't predict
exactly what the next character is
the better a probability distribution
you can put over the next
character you can then use an arithmetic
encoder to uh
right you don't have to know whether
it's an e or an i you just have to put
good probabilities on them and then
you know code those and if you have it's
a bits of entropy thing
right
you